Speaker 1: One of the things that is important
to prevent, because once the cat is out of
the bag, it's very difficult to get it back
in is the rewriting of history any time that
we can.
And when it comes to the last couple of years,
the pandemic, the Trump administration, et
cetera, we've been covering it all closely
with you with no interruption.
And so it gives us sort of this perspective
where we can remember what things were like
last year or two years ago when the right
tries to rewrite history for political advantage
or whatever the case may be.
Now this is a politically biased show in the
sense that this might come as a shock to some
of you, which is a problem, but this is not
a news reporting show.
This is a news, commentary and analysis show.
I'm on the left.
I'm a progressive.
That's my perspective.
But one of the things that I always try to
do or try not to do, depending on your perspective,
is I don't want to toss the political football
back and forth on issues that are not really
worthy of that.
And you know that on debt and deficit.
I don't play into the debt and deficit games
that both Republicans and Democrats play,
but Republicans play it more for sure because
they're the ones who claim to be the party
of fiscal responsibility as they define it
on gas prices, for example.
I've told you guys this, and when it was Bush
that was president, when it was Obama, when
it was Trump.
Now under Joe Biden, the American president
has very little influence over gas prices,
so I don't use gas prices as something to
praise or beat down a president.
These games are boring to me.
We're beyond them.
And now the issue of supply chain and shortages
is taking exactly the same tone and color.
It's Joe Biden's fault.
If as the other day when I went to the grocery
store, I couldn't get my Granny Smith apples
and I tweeted about it and got into a funny
exchange with Sam Seder about it.
But I'm not blaming Joe Biden for that.
Much like I didn't blame Donald Trump for
the shortages we saw earlier in the pandemic.
But the right wants to play the games, and
Tom not only is the right now blaming Joe
Biden for everything that's going on and saying,
Well, we have shortages because Secretary
of Transportation Pete Boudette, judge was
on paternity leave.
It even led to sort of homophobic stuff about,
Oh, he's learning to breastfeed and stuff
like this.
And now Republican Senator Tom Cotton.
Tom Cotton went on Laura Ingraham Show last
night and said we didn't have shortages under
Donald Trump during the first year of the
pandemic.
What this is beyond parody.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Early in the morning, you know,
we've had this pandemic for two years, Laura.
I don't remember inflation or supply chain
shortages or labor shortages that we've seen
this year in the first year of the pandemic.
What changed?
Joe Biden and the Democrats took power in
January.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine?
Can you imagine so labor shortages?
Well, that's very, very silly.
During the vast majority of Trump's presidency
during the pandemic, things were shut down.
There were too many workers in the sense that
a ton of businesses were closed.
Entertainment venues, movie theaters, sporting
events, many restaurants when it came to in-house
dining rather than just take out.
The situation was completely different.
That's why there weren't so-called labor shortages
under Trump.
Now, whether they are even really shortages
now, I think that that's actually the wrong
term for them.
But that's very silly.
But he's saying there were supply chain issues.
Do you guys remember toilet paper under Donald
Trump?
You couldn't find toilet paper when it came
back in stock.
There were limits.
No one package per person.
You can't get two packages of toilet paper
under Trump.
Was I blaming Trump for that?
Of course not.
It had nothing to do with Trump.
There were no N95 masks available.
People were desperate to get those surgical
masks.
You couldn't get hand sanitizer.
Couldn't find sanitizing wipes on Amazon.
Your local CVS couldn't find it.
The Lysol and other sprays, I wanted to get
rubbing alcohol sold out everywhere.
I ended up ordering a two pack from like target
online or something like that.
There were no canned foods you'd go to the
grocery store.
Not only was the grocery store packed with
lines waiting outside.
You couldn't find canned soup.
You couldn't find black beans.
You couldn't find pinto beans.
You couldn't find kidney beans, you couldn't
find cannellini beans, you couldn't find refried
beans.
You couldn't find spicy refried beans.
You couldn't find fava beans.
OK, I could go on.
I'm big on beans.
As you can tell the dry pasta section empty.
No spaghetti, no ziti, no penny, no gnocchi,
no pepper deli, no rotini.
Linguine angel hair.
Atopy, tagliatelle, fusilli macaroni farfalle
Consiglio.
You couldn't find lasagna noodles, guys, lasagna
noodles I was trying to make lasagna, couldn't
find them.
Costco was limiting how much meat you could
buy.
Meat was being rationed, folks, Whole Foods
said.
Only one of each kind of frozen fruit or vegetable.
I wanted to packages a frozen mango.
I was only allowed to buy one.
There was no flour and sugar.
People were baking like crazy due to boredom.
Couldn't dub ammunition was sold out everywhere.
Remember that?
And Tom Cotton doesn't remember anything like
this before this year under Joe Biden.
What?
But the important thing is, no one was blaming
Trump for that back then.
Even people on the left weren't saying It's
Trump's fault that there is no toilet paper
because it would be idiotic, just like the
other day at the grocery store.
I wanted my beloved Granny Smith apples and
they were sold out.
Thanksgiving probably had something to do
with it.
The green apple.
Very, very strong for Apple Pie.
Let's put that aside, it's not just but Joe
Biden's fault.
If anything, it's Thanksgiving's fault.
OK?
These guys have to give it up.
I mean, we it's on us not to allow them to
get away with this.
It was not Trump's fault, but there were shortages
under Trump, and it is not Joe Biden's fault
that now, you know, I wanted to get quiche
crusts the other day and they were sold out.
I'm not blaming Pete Boudette judges premature
twins that he has adopted.
It's just it just has nothing to do with that.
It's very silly.
Let's not allow them to rewrite history.